bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got amanda
here thank you for doing this
thank you for having me it's great to be
here all right
how did you get to consensus that is a
great question
i only asked great questions on the
podcast just so we're all clear go ahead
a lot of um luck along the way for sure
so i started
my career with a more kind of pure media
and marketing background
i worked for ariana huffington actually
at huffpost
okay um like directly for her yeah so i
was i worked very closely with her
part of her part of her team and sort of
circle there
and what we did was
really help move the online media
industry from
print into digital not that half post
was every print but it was one of the
first really mainstream
digital media outlets it really
popularized a lot of strategies around
aggregation
and um while i was there i'd just been
acquired by aol
and um we were um you know there's a
shift going on where a lot more of the
distribution was happening on social
media
digital media was changing and we
started to have this big creator
platform where people were creating
content
um and they they weren't being paid for
it and and it was it was interesting i
started seeing some of the
writing on the wall that you know all
the people creating content on facebook
creating content on twitter
they're adding so much value to these
platforms but they're not getting
remunerated for their work
so after a couple years there i left and
i started my own digital media platform
called slant
and what we tried to do was um reward
creators for their work
and so we had tons of college students
and journalism school students
writing a lot of first-person narratives
during the time when college
campus life was really in focus in the
media so we had a ton of um
ton of people writing ton of traffic and
uh we would pay out the creators 70
of ad revenue for the um the stories
that they wrote we would teach them
yeah yeah you can see where this is
going so we would teach them how to
market their content online we teach
them how to share it
um and um we would pay them out
so we were we had basically like a
microtransaction based business model
we were often splitting the dollar we
were splitting the cent
and we were dealing with third-party
payment processors um in order to do
this
and dealing with those third-party
payment processors even though this
business model makes logical sense
it made it not really make practical
sense and so when i first learned about
ethereum the idea that we could have
peer-to-peer transactions and just pay
directly i was like wow this solves my
random little startups problem
um i ended up um starting to get really
into
crypto and i i hadn't been part of the
community that had really been reached
by bitcoin
like i just wasn't on those kinds of
message boards it wasn't my demographic
so i came in through ethereum which is
really unique
because i happened to meet some of the
early ethereum folks just socially
hanging out in new york and sort of a
tech
founder crowd i met joe lubin i met
andrew keys i met
um sam cassette and
married him
maybe um and yeah i just got started
getting really involved and it kind of
blew my mind when they explained
ethereum to me
it solved the problem for for my
business and i thought about
you know all the different micro payment
based business models i thought about
remittances i thought about
uh what you could do with tax i i
thought about all kinds of different use
cases
um and i was sort of mindful and i knew
i had to do this so
then after slant i ended up coming back
and
joining consensus when it was under 100
people and
there wasn't really like a marketing
establishment there there wasn't really
this kind of narrative creation engine
there yet there were some early
businesses there were a lot of engineers
developers
and so what i really did is i built the
marketing function
at consensus marketing pr um
all that good stuff and and grew that
and kind of built the marketing
engine for helping to bring to market a
lot of the early consensus companies
so what's interesting to me is like in a
world that's so technical that's so
um kind of built on this idea of we're
going to build products we're going to
release them to the world there's
everything from liquidity bootstrapping
on out
marketing in pr seems to be like a skill
set that a lot of founders forget about
right and they just don't think about
that and so how did you look at hey i'm
basically going to be marketing
these whether they're decentralized or
centralized kind of more technical
projects like was that a
natural thing to do or did you guys have
to kind of learn how to do that
yeah sure so so the macro project was
telling the story of ethereum
and telling the story of ethereum is
really different from telling the story
of bitcoin
because the barrier to entry to
understanding what bitcoin does is a lot
lower
because you just have a bitcoin
fundamentally it solves an economic
problem it solves an interpersonal
social organizational problem ethereum
is a computer thing
and you have to have some kind of
knowledge of how technology works how
computers work
in order to fully grok ethereum and what
it can do
and so that barrier to entry is just
naturally higher and so it requires a
more robust
storytelling engine to get out to the
world not only how it works which
isn't necessarily even what you want to
do but what it does
and that's the thing that you really
want to bring across and you bring that
across with use cases
so all of the early projects they were
building at consensus
were and in the way i thought about them
use cases for ethereum that demonstrated
different capabilities of the technology
in the way that you can't just explain
it so um so
that was kind of the framing going in in
terms of individual projects
in the ecosystem on an individual level
i think like marketing is sort of a
dirty word because no one wants to feel
marketed too it's actually really
reasonable that that's the sentiment
around it
we see we we say marketing and people
who haven't dealt with marketing before
or haven't dealt with good marketing
think you know advertising they think
about like facebook ads they think about
twitter ads they're not thinking
this is how i learn about the tools that
i need in order to do the things i want
to do
and so good marketing in this space is
about understanding the audience
and the audience sometimes is developers
sometimes it's enterprises some but no
one wants to feel marketed to people
want to feel
like they're being introduced to tools
and software
that they want to use that serves their
use case makes sense that you would want
to speak to people in their language and
make sure that they have the emotional
connection to it right
um when you left consensus what you
decided to do
yeah so um after nearly four years as
cmo of consensus i
i stepped down to start serotonin my
company that i've um
co-founded with my my business partner
matthew isles
matthew was the ceo and co-founder of
civil
the blockchain media project that was
then fully acquired by consensus they
invested in it
that's how he and i really got to know
each other because he was also working
with me early on building up
the consensus marketing team and
he had run a digital marketing agency
for 10 years before that brought to
market
like over 60 mostly e-commerce startups
he actually wrote the general assembly
digital marketing coursework and so he's
educated all these people on how to do
digital marketing
and we decided to team up um because we
were basically
you know we love ethereum love consensus
felt like ethereum was basically
de-risked like it's successful
the rest of the world would think you
know what are you talking about it's so
new it's not across that line yet but
for us
you know ethereum is used like it it's
the foundation of defy
and so we were playing with d5 we were
playing with nfts we were playing with
dows
we want to be out where that kind of
edges we want to be dealing with that
you know that really complicated
storytelling that hasn't been broken
down yet and introduced to a mass
audience that's where we want to live
and so we started working with those
projects um so we started
you know really doing all of the
different marketing parts of marketing
with these projects so
helping them with uh with content with
with pr
with growth marketing product marketing
community
and really building strong
differentiated brands
and being able to work with a lot of
different projects is so cool because we
get to basically
paint with a broader brush and think
about these macro
narratives in the in the industry and
then fit these projects
into those narratives in ways that are
synergistic and complementary between
these projects and between their goals
so we've been able to really introduce a
lot of new concepts to the market this
cycle
and then we've been investing in having
our own in-house engineering and product
studio
and so we actually are um you know just
in the process right now of launching
our very first product
which is called mojito which is a
shopify like back end for minting nfts
we called it mojito because it's the
the sweetest way to mint and the idea
that we had there you know we we saw
from a number of our partners so we work
with sotheby's for example
on um on nfts we did that we did the
pack sale with sotheby's um
and we you know worked with them on an
ongoing basis on nfts and we noticed
that
a lot of these really prominent
companies or really prominent people
would rather
not partner with one of the marketplaces
they'd rather just host an nft sale on
their own
existing website instead of blending the
brands together
so we're like why not create this back
end and that's really been the synergy
between the the marketing
services that we offer we learn from
these companies what they all need
and then we can build that thing now
that we have an engineering team and so
in that situation
is that a just piece of software or is
that more of a crypto type
product where there's like a
decentralized element and there's tokens
and all of that like how do you think
so so it's both so the idea is that
anyone should be able to
add nft capabilities to their existing
website
just as easily as you should be able to
add an online store
we think that eventually it's going to
be as ubiquitous to have an nft as just
to have a
store on your website and you don't say
i launched a shopify store you just say
here's my store
and i think in the same way everyone
will have these nft
enabled sites where they're just
continuously selling nfts to people that
want to buy them
and we think that mojito is that
back-end that's going to subserve
that market demand because we don't need
to be out there with a with a flashy
brand saying we're a marketplace we just
want to be that back-end
kind of like wordpress we're in this
moment of transition where
you know we have this digital transition
we transitioned from the physical world
to the digital world
and now it's about transitioning the
digital world to the web three enabled
digital world
and taking all the artifacts that have
been digitized whether that's songs
whether that's
images whether it's video whatever it is
taking those artifacts
um if they have some kind of um
scarcifiable
value taking them and putting them in
nft form and we think that's just going
to be massive and ubiquitous
when you think about like what goes into
telling the right story for something
like this right like
how do you sit down and actually form
that story right so is this start with
the branding of it does it start with
if a client comes to you say okay you
know let's look at what the market
needs or what other people are doing
just like walk us through if i'm a
founder of a project or a company
what is the path for me to be able to do
this better given that
most people in the space are horrendous
at it and they'd be the first to say it
right like i don't understand about
marketing i don't know anything about
this so like i just don't do it so it
starts with an emoji
so there's a finite number of emojis you
have to pick one no
you're laughing but but literally that
is some truth to it i guess i also want
to like pay tribute to some of the
projects in the space that don't
officially engage
marketing services but that are actually
amazing at marketing something like base
like there's some of these d5 projects
that are just hilarious and unique in
their ability to market
so i definitely don't think you need to
engage like a formal marketing
service in order to be really great at
this and i think there are projects that
are great at this
i think we're pretty pretty great at it
too
so we usually start with brand
positioning and that's the foundation
so building brands that are memorable
that are differentiated and that create
a new category
and that's a really important thing so
the idea is like you could either be
one of something that everybody knows
what it is or you could be the first the
biggest
the best of something new that you
define and we've brought some new terms
into the market
and helped define them with our with our
various partners
and we know that those terms those
categories are working
through mimesis so if other people
repeat those back to us
if other projects are raising their
hands saying oh we're one of those
or oh we work like that or oh i want to
build one of those that's how we know
that we've actually been successful
so that's basically the foundation of
the house and then on top of that
the channels that we've noticed over and
over that everybody needs
are pr so earned media we consider that
you know part of a holistic marketing
strategy
not something that necessarily belongs
off on its own in a corner but something
that should be integrated into the whole
marketing process
content there's all kinds of content
that you need websites decks
white papers or like based you can just
write chicken a million times as your
white paper but you still need someone
to do that yeah they just wrote chicken
over and over
but you know they someone did that so
how many pages was this
it was a bunch of pages i remember i i
sort of uploaded onto my um
onto my ipad i was like i'm going to
read this before bed and then i open and
it just says
chicken but that's great right
i had a great experience it was part of
the marketing exactly like i
had an incredible incredible experience
with um with with that white paper the
best one i've ever had
and you don't even necessarily need a
white paper anymore so uh
that was a little bit like 2017 style
content but you
you need you need storytelling verbal
storytelling is a part of this
so pr content then um growth marketing
um you can't use crypto terms
uh on a bunch of paid platforms right
now so if you want to use terms like
bitcoin and crypto
it's hard to run a paid campaign on a
platform like facebook or twitter
but there are alternatives and i think
the ecosystem is generating its own
alternatives
we're actually building one we're
building a product called kismet which
is a peer-to-peer advertising
marketplace
which will enable crypto projects to do
paid programmatic advertising
without having to go to any of these
platforms where it's banned by directly
peer-to-peer connecting with influencers
more on that coming but there are growth
marketing things that you can
and should do depending on what kind of
outcomes you're looking for
we only really recommend doing growth
marketing once you can measure things
like
the actual lifetime value that you can
get out of a customer you're getting
some kind of revenue from it you should
be
you know you doing growth marketing
campaigns into your margins as opposed
to just spending a ton of money
um and then um product marketing
so making sure that all of the different
assets that a user or a visitor
might knock up against are arranged into
a funnel
and that that funnel is linked together
by calls to action and that you're
measuring the ability to draw people
through that funnel to take the actions
that you want them to take
it's product marketing and then um
community
so a huge aspect of all these projects
is community um
you know oftentimes it's the founders
that are doing a lot of the community
management especially early on as it
should be
um because bringing on those early
people and really engaging them
that's your core um so online that's you
know that's discord that's telegram
that's twitter
it's whatever you want it to be and
offline i think you know
physical in-person events are going to
come back and making sure that you have
an interesting differentiated presence
at those at those physical events
and then the other the other the other
bits and pieces that are that are
relevant here are
visual design you know making sure that
you don't just have a great verbal
presence that you have an interesting
visual presence
and then understanding how to do entry
into
various markets around the world so
english is still in my opinion
kind of the highest leveraged language
to have your content to have your story
played out in
mandarin is a close second and then
there are really interesting markets in
in japanese and korean obviously there
are markets in europe and africa and
south america
but a lot of those are actually
reachable through english
when you think of somebody who's done
this really well from like uh
creation of the product all the way
through from marketing perspective who
do you think's done at best
yeah um so there are a few a few a few
examples that i really like um
one of the folks on our team actually
was a head of comms at chain link and i
think chain links done a really great
job
i actually kind of call this strategy
the chain link strategy
where you do a lot of announcements you
make a lot of partnerships you announce
them and that lets you ping the market
over and over and over
um and so so i think that's a really
interesting thing especially because
you know not everybody in the market
sees every announcement coming from a
company
but the more announcements that you're
able to do the more times you're just
putting your name out and that's more
people that are going to end up seeing
it
um so that's a strategy that we've just
seen go really well
how do you do that and make sure that
people don't lose
faith or like confidence in that uh oh
you said that there's enough there's
another so there's another announcement
eventually it just all has to be true it
has to be stuff that you're actually
doing and you have to follow through on
the partnerships like you can't just
announce stuff and then not actually
follow through on the thing that you're
seeing
the trust of whoever you're on i mean
having what you say to the market be
accurate and following through on it
that's the most important thing so
there's a lot of distrust in the space
and so this is also a really great point
which is you're limited as a crypto
project in terms of what you can say
credibly about yourself
so you can say you know we're talking
about brand positioning i'm this
we produce this our competitive
advantage is this but um
you won't be believed unless you have
third party
proof points saying you are this so
partnerships having other
trusted known entity projects either in
the ecosystem or
in the enterprise world depending on who
your target market is
having them say oh we're working with
them and we're working with them
specifically on this
and having that testimonial really
showcase an aspect
of the functionality that's the main
value on so important
because you can only say so much about
yourself it's really about piecing
together perception
from a bunch of different third parties
and making sure they're confirming
the quality of what you're doing so
investors play a big role in that
so venture investors play a big role
kind of validating
uh the quality of projects partnerships
um play a play a huge role and then
influencers depending on the kind of
project there are sort of
trading influencers out there they're
also technology influencers really
trusted
tech leaders um and you know making sure
that you have prominent respected folks
aligning with your project and saying
great things about it
we're not talking about influence or
marketing of the kind where it's like
you pay an influencer to go say great
things about your product we're talking
about actually
authentic organic influencer marketing
by aligning with
smart people that are trusted by their
communities and
partnering with them to tell a story
when you think about
the thing the industry is the worst at
which part of this whole marketing and
pr
like body of work are you just like
we're atrocious as an entire industry at
x
oh yeah that's interesting um
uh i i think actually branding and
positioning is actually the the real
challenge i think a lot of people are
using the same language
even using the same images like i
remember in the um 2016-2017 cycle if i
saw one more website
that was kind of moving triangles
remember remember what everything was
those triangles and if you were really
sophisticated you you you would animate
your triangles they would sort of
connect with each other
and it sort of incepts this idea of the
the blockchain um so there's a lot of
similar imagery being used there's a lot
of similar language being used so it's
really hard to stand out especially with
everyone shouting at once so it's so
important to just do
good differentiation good category
creation it's not enough at this point
to say i'm an l1
you have to have a very specific
competitive advantage okay
here's how i'm better than ethereum or
here's here's the niche i'm occupying
that makes me that makes me different
um because you don't just get to say i'm
an l1 and say you know
my merits are just the merits of a
blockchain we're decentralized or
peer-to-peer no you have to go further
you they're they're existing winners in
those spaces and you have to
disambiguate
when you think about how you spend your
day is it
a hundred percent on kind of the agency
and marketing services
uh with some of the building in there or
do you do other stuff like how do you
just think about how you break down how
you spend your time
yeah for sure so it's a mix um it's
i i sit sort of at the intersection of
those two
parts of our business so we have this
product studio where we're building
products
and we have this marketing services
business where we're working with
partners
and these things connect really deeply
so what i'm trying to think about all
day
is what's the connective tissue here so
across our services business
i'm thinking what's the macro story of
what's going on in the ecosystem
who's telling this story and how do we
get our
partners into that story in a way that's
going to be synergistic and beneficial
to them
and at the same time what's missing here
what's missing from this picture how do
we build into what's missing
in a way that's going to be enhancing to
all of it i'm a big fan of the
rising tide lifts all boats jam that's
always been true in my interactions with
the industry
i think it makes a lot of sense and so i
think of myself as kind of a
a puzzle solving storyteller trying to
figure out okay there's a piece here
that's shaped like this there's a piece
here that's shaped like this
what can we build what can we connect
what can we
augment or tell the story of in some way
that's what i'm always looking for and
when i look around the market
the projects that i'm really attracted
to tend to be projects
where um where there's a real skeleton
there and
you know sometimes i compare um product
r d uh you know engineering and
marketing to kind of like the
the skeleton and the muscle on a body
and you have to have that sort of hard
core of an actual product something that
works something that makes sense
and then um you know if it's just bone
you're not going to get anywhere you
have to attach muscle to it and then you
can take it on a walk
and same goes if you're all muscle with
no bone you're just going to
flop around and not be able to go
anywhere so it's about that balance of
finding
teams that really have the goods but
aren't punching at their weight class in
terms of
having their story be understood by the
market and we help them get there and
further
pretty much you're looking for a
mispriced asset yeah right totally
totally that's it same thing as like
investing that that's exactly right
we're creating
we're looking for in market
inefficiencies and we're making them
into an efficiency
and really what you're doing is you've
only can do this with
things that have substance because if
you put the best marketing
at something that doesn't have any
substance then it ends up not even being
that bad it's not going to work exactly
yeah
when you think about geographies is
there a difference
you mentioned kind of language earlier
but is there a difference between the
u.s markets europe
uh asia you know any other market
yeah in terms of like how you think
about what said not just the language
that it's set in
yeah very much so um so in
in mandarin and also a bit in korean
no i don't i wish i did um mandarin
korean
japanese like in in the asian markets
that i've
helped launch projects into in general
i've noticed that the communities there
are very price focused obviously the
english-speaking ones and european
obviously a lot of communities are price
focused but
there's no narrative or there's less of
a narrative about being in it for the
technology
there's less of this insistence that
influencers be authentic or organic
they expect that things are pay to play
a bit more there and so
kol's or which is what they call
influencers are a big part of
the marketing tactics also the platforms
are really different um i remember when
i started doing um
work in mandarin speaking speaking
markets
noticing that you know wechat has these
500 person
groups and it's an interesting tactic
because it means you can't actually
assemble a bunch of people and speak to
them at once and organize them
you know what i'm saying here but um you
you break it all up
which means that the process of managing
those communities isn't that scalable
because you need more community managers
and you have to
hire more community managers linearly to
maintain all those wechat it's almost
like somebody wants to make sure that
it's very hard to talk to lots of people
at once yeah but it's but i'm trying to
you know
it's a different it's a different spirit
in terms of why people
largely i mean of course their
exceptions are interacting with the
space and the actual platforms have
different
logic to them and different constraints
so there there's there's both kind of a
larger narrative difference and there's
a um
and there's a procedural kind of
tactical uh difference and then
in the in the english speaking markets
you know it's very much about having
authentic support for these projects and
i i find it kind of um like almost
maybe tacky isn't the right word but it
it it feels
wrong to have a project that is
talking about price and that's all about
price it needs to be a project that
genuinely just wants to put a cool
technology into the world
and then the value of that technology is
reflected perhaps by the market
if the market's able to properly
understand the value of the technology
but that's the order of operations it
almost feels like there's some
crazy way the exact same thing that's
true in software startups and kind of
venture capital of just like
the companies that build products that
solve people's problems or that people
want
they win and everything else kind of
falls to the wayside and struggles
same thing here right it's going to
build substance totally true same thing
here
but there's just so much exuberance in
the market and so much is linked to
cycles
that there's not always that logic to it
sometimes just the rising tide
is such a strong tide that it lifts all
boats the good the bad and the ugly
and so sometimes that makes it hard to
see the logic
of a project that's actually technically
superior succeeding over one that's
inferior
but oftentimes that's temporary so it's
almost like
the sustainable strategy is what i
described but sometimes you can
have an unsustainable strategy and still
benefit just because right
so you can't go in and say i've noticed
that this token is performing really
well so i bet this technology is really
high quality
that's a very difficult jump to make and
be correct necessarily
but i think in a really exuberant market
like this if you have good technology
and you're able to tell a good story
around it you can get the market to
reflect that back to you
so i've recorded with sam
the other end of the spectrum is like
the whole degen
yield farming etc uh where do you kind
of think of yourself in terms of like
where you spend most of your time
yeah so i would say like ideologically
i'm like the djanus dj
but i appreciate that the whole spectrum
is necessary in order to get everyone
there so we work with projects that are
all over that spectrum and very happily
so because there's this macro
picture which is that there's value
moving from the
centralized economy that's controlled by
a bunch of individuals
discretionarily there's value moving
from that
context into a decentralized context and
it doesn't just
hop over there it needs to move over
there over bridges
and those bridges are often centralized
companies like think like coinbase
like they're basically a tollbooth on
that bridge and that's why they've been
so financially successful because
they're literally just charging
to be that link so you can have this
centralized
trust you can have someone you know
custody your crypto for you
but you can get the upside of
participating or the
community incentives or whatever it is
of participating in this
transition toward decentralization you
can you can have these decentralized
coins um and so we're seeing all these
businesses cropping up along that
spectrum you know we're obviously seeing
a huge rise of dexes
and so you know maybe the value has that
that moved into coinbase maybe now it's
moving into dexes and so you see this
progression
and so maybe you know i i'm very values
aligned with what's going on
at the at the extrema of
decentralization because i think that's
really interesting
and i think that's driving the whole
thing but i recognize the need for the
entire
uh bridge and support you know all of it
if i shut off the podcast and i asked
you what's like the biggest
thing that you think you know that other
people aren't paying attention to right
now what would you say
um i would say that a lot of the
trends that are coming from d5 actually
aren't flashes in the pan
and are long-term things that are going
to stick with us
so for example i think there's something
really macro there's a macro negotiation
going on
about the value of engineering talent
like that's a huge macro right
so right now vcs even in the last cycle
in in non-crypto companies vcs have been
able to
use capital to eat a certain chunk of
cap tables
and engineering talent gets remunerated
x amount and
things like fair launches and these
kinds of d5 protocols that vcs can't
really buy into
are a refutation of the
types of cuts that vcs have been able to
take
so there's a species get slammed down to
smaller percentage exactly so
there's a macro negotiation being done
at the level of the technology
between engineering talent and venture
capital and i think that's a really
interesting
thing that's going on and i think you
know engineering talent is calling out
venture capital
as undervaluing them and overvaluing
themselves so that's interesting
um and one thing real quick on that is i
guess
there's like a venn diagram of the
people with capital and the people with
engineering
uh expertise that like if you sit at the
center of that that's actually the most
valuable position to be in right because
you can put large
pools of capital to work and also you
can do it in a technical way and there
that's where the return is
yeah and i think also the other the
other trend is
as we build out this decentralized
ecosystem
increasingly the financial products that
you're using the
you know things that you're buying
things that you're dealing with you
don't have to take your money
out of the system and so that's that's
the other thing that i think is going on
is
you know right now we have this bridge
we have these toll roads with these big
toll booths on them
but what if we're moving into this world
so much that
we don't need to move back and we can
actually live our full 360 degree
life in our decentralized context
without having to
go backward into fiat i think i think
that's what's being built here
i think that uh everyone i bring in here
is pretty much convinced that's where
we're headed
yeah exactly exactly and so i don't know
if i know things that
that that other people don't i probably
know about some things that are going to
launch that are
pretty cool but yeah feeling very i'm
very excited about where things are
going awesome i have three questions for
you you could ask me one to finish up
yeah most important book you've ever
read
you know i think every business book is
based on how to make friends and
influence people
and every other like business advice
book is some kind of you know derivative
or like bastardization
of how to make friends and influence
people so that one's just been
incredibly
powerful um for me um one of my favorite
just books in general
that i always love and always come back
to it's ender's game i just i just love
that story
and i i got to a point once where i
always knew what the next line of it was
going to be and
i just love i love adventure i love
sci-fi i think that's part of the spirit
of the space
um you know some of the neil stevens and
stuff is awesome so i read a lot of
fiction read a lot of sci-fi but in
terms of business
how to how to win friends and influence
people is what's happening classic for a
reason
yeah for sure because it's actually a
really marketing
style book because it's about and it's
amazing that someone had to invent this
now but instead of thinking about what
you want and telling people what you
want you think about
what other people want and you present
what you want in the context of what
they want
and that's the ultimate marketing
mentality is just
not just thinking about yourself
thinking about what other people want
what other people need and shaping
things so that you're meeting their
needs and building things so you meet
their needs
it's not rocket science i mean but
someone had to come up with that
right which is wild yeah exactly
sleep uh our friends over at sleep sent
me a thermo-regulated bed so i can make
it super super cold
uh i sleep like a baby now you sleep
like five six hours now i'm like eight
nine hours
what's your sleep schedule i sleep a lot
i'm a big sleeper
i do you know eight nine hours i have an
aura ring i have a chili pad we have a
lot of like
you should get rid of the chili pad and
you should oh yeah okay great um
so we we can even edit out the
the reference to that you know i'm a
huge fan
of having you know a nice cool a nice
cool
sleep environment very dark like to
really
really close the blinds um i love the
aura ring i love tracking my sleep i
think it made me
have healthier habits to just kind of
see like what gets measured gets managed
yep do you sleep a lot are you a big
sleeper eight nine hours nice like
need it the eight sleep is game changer
both my
wife and i like when we lay down on it
she actually looks a little bit warmer i
like it colder it's great because it
doesn't try to like
come over and just take part of the bed
i stay over there
um and i do like a little a little cbd
before bed cbd
that's me there's a company uh house of
water oh i thought i thought you might
know it cbd company yeah
house of wise is uh focused on female uh
use cases of cbd ah got it house of wise
i'll send it to you awesome that's great
uh aliens are you believer or
non-believer
i think there's an infinite universe and
um
if that's the case then there's probably
all kinds of all kinds of stuff
got to be out there right gotta gotta be
out there i i i think they're all kinds
of intelligences you know like
it isn't necessarily our kind of
intelligence um i think you know ants
look at us and they think
nothing probably and i think probably
there are other kinds of intelligences
that have the same
we look at these relationships yeah we
think they're a bunch of ants so there
might be something looking at us that
way
yeah i mean that's crazy to think about
but yeah uh
you could ask me one question what do
you have for me what question um
let's see what would it take to convince
you to buy eth
i don't think it's so much like
convincing me to buy each right like
what would make you make you buy either
by the way
here's the deal everyone forgets i'll
say one thing everyone forgets i
actually started
uh similar to you the way that i found
crypto
was mining eth mm-hmm people don't so
if you if you're mining then you know i
think that counts i was mining eth
very early on um i still uh so i did it
personally
um i actually here's a wild story for
you i took my facebook stock
and i sold it 50 of it or so i put into
my bank account
in cash and 50 i bought gpu rigs and i
started mining
and the pitch to me was from somebody
who just was like hey that's like data
centers but better
i didn't understand the difference
between eth bitcoin anything else like
it just was
hey you're going to buy this computer
and you're going to mine it started
mining it and this is like end of 2016.
well we're like mining eth and also it's
like
10 to 30 to 100 and by like may of 2017
it's like 100 bucks
and i was like what is it you know like
what is this thing going
and so uh one of the mistakes that i
made was i started trying to oh it ran
up to 200
i should sell it and then buy it like
what i'm not a trader i don't know what
i'm doing
right uh but i kept those machines for
quite a long time then what i did was
a company that i'm an investor in uh
with a friend of mine jason williams he
is also a very large investor on the
same company
we then built a mine
there on site it's a power company to
take car tires to turn it into
uh electricity and rather than sell it
with the grid built this
uh mine so technically it is still
mining
ether uh so it's not so much like i've
fought it or done any of this stuff
um there's this weird thing of like if
you own a bunch of bitcoin
if you sell it you pay taxes so like i
do think of a lot of like people get
locked in right like if you when you
uh are at consensus you buy a bunch of
eth you
you know get paid and eat all this stuff
if then all of a sudden one day you're
like ah you know what i'm going to go
buy a bunch of bitcoin
it's like new dollars into the system
right rather than
which gets to the point again about
keeping everything in the system
great it's crazy right but like laws
have to change all this stuff
the other thing is um there's an
argument for
pure financial gain right so like forget
uh
the um
forget like the uh the narratives around
the assets the tribalism around the
assets i helped make the narratives
right
i can forget that easily if i say here's
20 assets which one's going to perform
best financially
right uh i actually think bitcoin and
ether
are like in the same bucket in that
spectrum
the returns are commoditized by crypto
standards at this point
so even if bitcoin goes up 20x right it
goes to a million dollars
or so from where it's about right now
and that takes through the next half
five years most people on crypto are
gonna be like
bitcoin 20x five years like that's such
a small return for such a long period of
time
which is the traditional world sounds
nuts yeah of course ether maybe that's
30x in five years right people are like
that's
not that super interesting right they
want the 100x in a month they want the
you know the dj and stuff right
and so i think that a lot of times in
some weird way there's almost like this
barbell strategy of like
if you have bitcoin and then you want
pure financial return
like something i invested in uh recently
is built on top of bitcoin so
you know makes a ton of sense for where
i spend much of my time but it has a lot
of the elements and it went up a bunch
in a very short period of time and so
when you think of that i think it's more
so
uh you're making an opportunity cost
decision from my standpoint
right now what people forget is if
you're going to use some of this stuff
you need eth right so if you want to buy
nfts for example what do you need
usually you have to use ethe to do it
mojito is going to enable people to pay
with credit cards okay
perfect that's a good plug
but but i think that a lot of times too
you have to separate out like are people
using it or are they holding it as an
investment asset
right have stable coins and so i think
that a lot of times what ends up
happening is people are forced to use an
asset there's some systems where you're
forced to use bitcoin there's some
systems where you're forced to use eth
sometimes actually you're forced to use
a stable coin right and sometimes
there's something else
and so i think it's less about like um
uh
some like religious view on like
anti-eth and it's much more about
bitcoin i'm obviously a big believer in
i feel like that is the
safest bet in the industry it's actually
like the least risky thing to bet on
just because of the
asset the monetary policy the uh
adoption et cetera
and then it's like if i'm gonna do
anything i wanna do like the riskiest
things i can find
right and so you get that like almost
barbell strategy within an industry
now you and i sound absolutely insane
like a traditional finance person
what do you mean like you you i think
would have the viewpoint of like
eth is the thing that is the least risky
you know in your opinion or whatever
like it's very not risky yeah and then
you'll go do a bunch of other stuff
right so whether it's bitcoin or eth
forget the debate for a second that's
actually like the least risky stuff in
the industry
totally but to like a traditional
financial person they're like you guys
are
nuts like this is you know half a
percent in my portfolio it's the
riskiest thing i own like it's going you
know either to zero or
up a lot and so i think it's all
perspective of just like how do you want
to allocate your assets and for me it's
outside of bitcoin it's pure financial
return and so the further out on the
risk curve you can get the better you're
going to get a return rather than just
basically get like the second biggest
thing well that's a great answer to my
question and
i feel like uh the times of being tribal
and religious about these
stupid it doesn't make sense i mean in a
bull market you'll get a lot of people
throwing off the
the shackles of religion in a in a bear
market people
band together so let's see what happens
humans are great
humans subcomfortable at least true
where can we send people to find you on
the internet um
my twitter is amanda cassette
c-a-s-s-a-t-t
um and my company serotonin serotonin
dot co
awesome thank you for doing this we'll
do it again thanks for having me